the IMF is uniquely trained and highly  motivated specialists without equal  immune to any countermeasures  but it is an agency of chaos the time  has come to dissolve the IMF now I want  you to choose your next words very  carefully  where is Hamid the last I heard he was  tracking the syndicate  how come the CIA has never discovered  any Intel regarding the syndicate you  want to play an answer or the truth  we've never met before right fire me  Bengie Ethan where are you The Syndicate  is real a rogue nation trained to do  what we do an anti-imf they're coming  after us with everything they've got  you ready this may very well be our last  mission let's make it count  so what's the play you want to bring  down the syndicate  it's impossible  how do you know we can trust her  desperate times  desperate measures  bigger seatbelt on you asking me that  now  oh hey boys what did I miss  pieces  open the door  door yeah I'm trying  you